nowhere left to hide for one of the
fbi's most wanted drug lords not even
the mountains of his native sinaloa
state in mexico rafael caro quintero
once the us's primary supplier of heroin
cocaine and marijuana finally caught
he's accused of killing dea agent
enrique camarena nicknamed kiki an
american officer whose tortured body was
found a month after he went missing in
1985.
quintero had begun serving a 40-year
sentence for the killing but in 2013 an
appeals court overturned the verdict
by the time his guilt was confirmed by
the supreme court he'd already been
whisked away in a waiting car
the former leader of the infamous
guadalajara cartel went back to a life
of drug trafficking unleashing bloody
turf battles in the northern sinaloa
state
the strategy of the dea and the mexican
security forces has to be
to to take off these very senior people
in the cartels but when they when they
do it sort of creates a job opening at
the top it doesn't actually change any
of the structural problems which mean
that cartels and organized crime are
able to flourish
quintero's re-arrest comes just days
after mexico's president met his
american counterpart claiming progress
on tackling illicit narcotics in what
has long been a tense matter between the
two countries
so proud of its achievement the mexican
navy even released a photo of the search
dog that found quintero
but the capture came with losses 14
people died in a helicopter crash during
the operation
the navy called it an accident
caro quintero believed to be in his 60s
is being held at a maximum security
prison near mexico city as he awaits his
immediate extradition to the u.s
saudia chowdhury sky news